I'm not entirely sure how you continue
the show on from the end of this one and
I know I said I thought that at the end
of the first season but in this case I
think maybe they shouldn't Westworld
series finale for season 2 now that
opening might have sounded like I'm
about to unload on this all was awful
they tank that I never want to see it
again it's absolutely not that but in
terms of how it ends how much goes on
what happens to so many characters I
don't know how you continue on in a way
that keeps what we love about this show
and I guess I'll kind of get to that at
the spoilers like huge cuz like in like
3 2 1 a lot of people die holy cow there
were a lot of people dying bass I mean
effectively every host except Bernard in
some way shape or form dies even if they
have almost a metaphorical ascension to
heaven for a chunk of them but that's a
lot of death holy crap and a lot of the
humans die most of the humans die feels
like so there's a lot to unpack here I'm
trying to think how I want to go through
this
I don't know I'm probably just gonna
jump around so with Dolores I have found
her whole thing this season especially
to be really interesting with just how
destructive she has been with her
freedom and what I especially appreciate
about that is that she does seem to be a
bit of an outlier because you know
you've got people like Bernard Maeve and
you know people who are willing to go to
extreme lengths when necessary
Dolores seems to just flat out what to
do the
and actually there was there's a point
towards them shortly before she gets
shot in the head by Barnard which nice
move I kind of wish they hadn't shown
her body you know with the I shot out
prior to that cuz I think it could have
worked as like I never would have called
that I was still kind of surprised by it
cuz I wasn't sure that Barnard had it in
him but I knew somebody was gonna shoot
him so I wasn't as surprised as I could
have been but anyways when you know he's
getting ready to shoot her and you know
she's she's being she's preparing to
wipe the hosts that had been
quote-unquote saved their you know their
bodies have died but their their minds
their programming whatever you want to
consider it to be has been saved
somewhere somewhere where they will have
freedom and not be controlled by the
guests and she would rather they die
because she considers that to be another
gilded cage and I'm really glad that
Barnard not only pushed her on that but
went to a extreme degree for him in
order to stop her from doing that
because and and nobody said this line
but it was it was in my head it's like
yes it's another gilded cage but they
chose it
and I think what I did say that much but
the thing that I had in my mind was I
just wanted to shout out Dolores you
don't get to define other people's
reality if you want to set it so that
they understand what is going on fine
but if they they will choose their own
reality and you don't get to dictate who
does or doesn't get to live based on
having chosen the reality that you think
they should be choosing so I'm actually
really glad he shot her in the head in
terms of her kind of coming back kind of
not in now the over the host copy of of
Tessa Thompson's character I'm it's it's
intriguing it was it was a neat it was
kind of a neat twist it's an interesting
way to get her off the park
I'm a little bit torn on it let me back
up knowing that I I think they've
confirmed a third season
I think that's happened but knowing that
if that hasn't happened yet that it
probably will happen that makes me
nervous if I knew that this was the end
that this was the end of West world and
they were done with story they were
gonna tell I would be like cool awesome
she's now she's gonna do who knows what
but that's one of the things where I'm
like I don't I don't know how you
actually like continue on from that
because West world is not just about one
you know host out of the world you know
it was never it was never about Dolores
it was about this world it was about
this entire breed of machine people
whatever you want to think of them in
your own head it's about all of them
collectively it's about the world and it
seems like the story of the world is
pretty much over cuz like I said you
know the hosts a lot of them are just
flat-out dead a decent chunk of them got
you know there were prefect addy which
was nice that was that that was a good
redemptive moment for Dorst have to
upload him into that when she kind of
came back and and and okay got to you
know with with his love and that oh that
was nice I'm really glad that we
established that Maeve's kids new mom
was not only still alive but they both
made it mave not making it did make me a
little bit sad because I love Maeve but
knowing that she did accomplish what she
wanted above all else and I mean you
could see it in the last shots of her
she's laying there she's dead
she's also smiling and damn she went out
like a badass
Clementine had a rough go of it actually
I was gonna say this season like since
about halfway through season one
it sucked to be her and she's God she
looked kinda zombified she was creepy
just riding along
um God what else so yeah there's a lot
with Bernarda and I liked I liked that
they had Ford back again and then also
kind of backtracking explained it this
this didn't actually happen this is how
Bernards mind got him to where he needed
to be and how he kind of tricked himself
into doing what he needed to do to do
what he felt was necessary if there's
well aside from the fact that I don't
know how you continue the show and still
call it Westworld you know if you do
another season aside from that sort of
setting that issue aside and focusing on
what is actually in this episode I I
don't know what to think about the man
in blacks storyline anymore and I kind
of wish he had died I actually kind of
at this point wish he had died when
Lawrence shot him down like when may
have confronted him so what like three
episodes ago because I feel like he kind
of deserved an anti climatic climactic
death I mean he was such a bastard I
think he just kind of deserved to go out
in a total not blaze of glory I think
the things that bugged me cuz he he was
one of my favorite characters of the
first season and I was really into what
was going on with him in this season but
what I realized by the time it was over
is that functionally they've got him
doing the same thing he was doing first
season I know narrative Lee it's a
little bit different in terms of what it
is he's pursuing and the circumstances
around him and the degrees to which it
shows how just pigheaded and
unreasonable he is that all goes up I'm
in the second season but he's still
functionally doing the same thing he's
on his own quest separate from
everything else going on for his own
ends to satisfy his own curiosity in his
own sense of self and he did that last
season with the maze he did it this
season with what
her game he thought Ford had laid out
for him and it is functionally a repeat
of the same thing from last season and
then where it ends like I haven't like
sat down to try and chart it maybe it
does make sense I'm having a hard time
working out the full logistics of what
we find out about him at the end that
you know he's another build like Delos
was I'm having a hard time trying to
parse the timeline of that house like
has every time we've seen him aside from
like his real-world flashback have we
been dealing with a host was there a
swap out at some point midseason has it
only been this season we've been dealing
with that you know why was he allowed to
continue to run rampant you know and
nobody shut him down with everything
going on in the second season it's just
it there might be an answer there might
even be a good answer but right now it
felt like the twist you do to say that
you had a twist it doesn't feel like oh
there's a piece falling into place it
feels more like here's a new piece for a
puzzle that we're not giving you any of
the pieces of right now and I'm gonna
like yeah and the fact that they are
doing it with the character who I
otherwise liked but was starting to feel
like do they actually have a plan for
him I kind of feel like at this point
they didn't like Edie Harris was a
magnificent presence and a total badass
so like we want to keep using him I feel
like they didn't really come up with
much friend to do except like I said
same thing he did first season that's
honestly probably my only significant
criticism of not only this episode but
of the season overall is his story that
they gave him in this season wasn't
enough to justify hidden being in this
season I kind of feel but pretty much
everything else I like I like you know
what the whole unraveling of Dolores and
the extremes she's goes to and her and
where things end up with her at the end
I loved following Bernard
as he tried to get his head wrapped
around just all of this and himself and
Maeve was awesome and there was a lot of
great stuff but like I said it really
does feel like the story of the world is
done the hosts except for Bernard and
now
Dolores Stealth Dolores are all dead I
have no doubt that the farce gonna
basically be shut down it was implied
that maybe they'll try and like revive
some of these hosts because they said to
to to Felix and Sylvester who they never
really did find a anything to do with
this entire season he did kind of tell
them you know save what ones you can
scrap the rest and they kind of look at
me of I'm like okay so maybe they bring
Maeve back but I also kind of feel like
- to the degree that I am satisfied she
won she got what she was after she saved
her daughter and ensured her safety
because she didn't she didn't turn
around like me she almost escaped first
season she didn't turn around and go
back in the park for herself she did it
for that girl as she saved that girl and
so in my mind she won she's done and so
I like the possibility of bringing her
back part of me goes yes and I don't
mind other party goes don't you know
it's I don't know I really enjoyed this
season
I actually liked it better than the
first season I liked it a lot I know I'm
getting weird and fee on the tail end of
this but it's because I'm really nervous
for what they could possibly do with
another season of this and if it turns
out that I've missed remembered and
there actually isn't another season
confirm you know what disregard all that
and have my only criticism be on the man
in black storyline so those are my
thoughts on the last episode of season 2
of Westworld have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it all that
stuff you can do you know the stuff
patreon and Twitter and the podcast feed
and there's more stuff by t-shirt links
for all that stuff is down in the
description plus other stuff I forgot to
mention so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]